dans l'actualité ce soit un début de
week-end du 8 mai chaotique pour des
milliers de voyageurs le trafic a été
interrompu plusieurs heures à la gare du
nord suite à un incendie
bonne nouvelle sur les routes le nombre
de morts a baissé de plus de 18% au mois
d'avril le gouvernement lance une
nouvelle campagne aux états unis barack
obama fait un pas sans doute décisif
vers la candidature après sa large
victoire en caroline du nord
hillary clinton a donné pour la première
fois des signes de conciliation en
birmanie si les premières images non
officiels donnent un aperçu de l'ampleur
du drame
mais l'aide humanitaire reste bloquée
faut-il utiliser le droit d'ingérence
oui répond bernard kouchner il est notre
invité bonsoir et attend ce soir il n'y
aura pas de nouvelle augmentation des
tarifs du gaz pour le consommateur la
hausse de 1 5% évoqué hier pour les
canalisations ne sera pas répercutée sur
la facture
explications dans un instant enfin
contrats signés pour le pont le plus
long du monde 40 km pour relier le qatar
au royaume de bahreïn il sera construit
par le français vinci bonsoir et
bienvenue à tous d'abord donc cette
grande vague de départs pour le week-end
prolongé du 8 mai du lundi de pentecôte
soirée marquée par une grosse pagaille
et gare du nord à paris où le trafic a
été interrompu pendant plusieurs heures
en raison d'un incendie sur les voies
sur place paul indoor dit patrice
brugère l' incendie a pris sur les rails
à 2 km de la gare
du coup ici l'électricité a été coupée
le trafic paralysé en cette veille de
jour férié les voyageurs s'interroge
jusqu'à ce que les personnes soient
sécurisés c'est
vers les plus tard mais bon les aléas
des transports en colère parce que c'est
pas assez souvent c'est souvent qu'il ya
des problèmes
normalement je suis sur la ligne b mais
là j'essaye d'avoir runing une grande
ligne pour contenir pour qu'on puisse
venir me chercher alors qu'il est
l'électricité vient d'être rétablie la
sncf annonce un retour progressif à la
normale bonsoir agnès molinier vous êtes
en direct sur place que s'est il passé
exactement
alors écoutez vous l'avez entendu c'est
un incendie et l'eau utilisée par les
pompiers pour l'éteindre est bien
bloquée a coupé l'électricité et il ya
eu une panne sur un rayon de huit
kilomètres autour de la guerre est donc
plus aucun train c'était donc une grosse
paralysie alors il ya le trafic reprend
un eurostar est arrivé il ya à cgv qui
était en train d'arriver en ce moment et
ça devrait reprendre selon la sncf dans
deux heures mais vous l'entendez il ya
encore beaucoup de monde autour de moi
des milliers de passagers qui à cause de
la chaleur aussi se sont égayés un peu
sur les voies ce qui retarde encore le
départ des trains c'est une grosse une
grosse soirée pour le trafic sncf
puisque c'est le week end est ici la
gare du nord et la première gare
d'europe la troisième au monde
il faut savoir que d'ordinaire il y a
ici à la gare du nord un train toutes
les 3 minutes
merci agnès et bon courage pour ceux qui
attendent sur les routes maintenant
d'abord un bon chiffre le nombre de
morts a baissé de plus de 18% au mois
d'avril 294 tués tout de même mais il y
en avait 4 111 l'an dernier le
gouvernement a choisi cette veille de
week-end pour lancer une nouvelle
campagne choc très réaliste vous allez
le voir mais sans hémoglobine malaria ou
nous alain location c'est le coup de fil
que chacun regrette marie oui un break
gris métallisé
oui c'est ma fille
comment ça un accident ce verset le
nouveau message de la sécurité routière
pour sensibiliser les français
une scène que jean louis borloo a
lui-même vécu en apprenant la mort de
son meilleur ami sur une route
départementale
une voiture a fait demi-tour devant lui
et il est mort chez moi je crois que
toute famille
toute famille française a eu ce coup de
fil nous pouvons tous arrêter fin alors
faisons le
chaque jour les routes compte 13 morts
et 300 blessés en ce début de long
week-end de mai traditionnellement
meurtrier
les autorités ne transige pas avec les
mauvaises habitudes que les français
semblent reprendre 54 ans aujourd'hui
sur autoroute roulait à 140 150 km à
leur bon y'a rien de dangereux là dedans
pourtant 9 accidents sur 10 sont dus au
comportement des conducteurs 500 radars
s'ajouteront donc chaque année aux 2000
existants par ailleurs dans chaque
coffre il faudra bientôt trouver un
gilet et un triangle fluorescents c'est
pas obligatoire à partir du mois de
juillet voilà j'ai pas le thriller ça ça
peut éviter des accidents quand même
quand on change une roue je pense que
c'est bien oui
en six ans d'efforts onze mille vies ont
été sauvées cent mille blessés éviter
nouvel objectif passer sous la barre des
3000 morts par an d'ici à 2012
et si vous prenez la route rester
concentré on apprend qu'une touriste
belge de 87 ans a été oublié sur une
aire de repos d'autoroute à montélimar
par son frère de 88 ans il s'en est
aperçu après 50 km à l'étranger ça n'est
pas encore officiellement la victoire
mais ça y ressemble pour barack obama
large succès en caroline du nord hier
défaite honorable dans l'immédiat n'a
cette fois le sénateur semble bien en
passe de décrocher l'investiture
démocrate pour la maison blanche sur
place alain de chalvron aaron dimon la
confiance retrouvée
barack obama peut souffler sa victoire
en caroline du nord n'était pas acquise
les avec 14 points d'avancé sur hillary
qu'il donne il prend le large et peu
concentré ses tirs sur john mccain et
john mccain ce serait comme donner un
troisième mandat george bush et lui vont
pas nous le permettre
besoin de changement et c'est pourquoi
il faudra être une pour l'élection en
novembre tout clippers hillary clinton
fait contre mauvaise fortune bon coeur
et tente de transformer sa victoire
étriquée dans l'indiana embryons on
était loin derrière et ce soir on a
inversé la vapeur et grâce à vue on file
tout droit vers la maison blanche
mais bill sait mieux que quiconque que
cette soirée marque un tournant
et au détour d'une phrase il à rire
entre les griffes et fait patte de
velours
quoi qu'il arrive je travaillerai pour
le nominer du parti démocrate parce que
ce qui compte c'est de gagner les
élections laurent battante hillary
clinton poursuivra sans doute la
campagne jusqu'à la dernière primaire le
3 juin les hier c'était pour elle un peu
le chant du cygne bonsoir alain de
chalvron vous êtes en direct à
indianapolis
question simple est ce qu'on peut dire
ce soir que les jeux sont faits
on écoute et on peut pas exclure un
nouveau bouleversement cette campagne
n'en a pas manqué un gros scandale qui
contraindrait barack obama a jeté
l'épongé à se retirer de la campagne
mais disons que en principe
sinon effectivement je l'histoire
retiendra vraisemblablement que c'est
ici hier que s'est jouée cette élection
le quotidien de new york le new york
post titré ce matin elle est cuite elle
est postée très exactement aimablement
et c'est un peu la tonalité générale si
vous voulez elle ne peut plus
mathématiquement refaire son retard en
termes de délégués élus et en ce qui
concerne les super délégué vous savez
ces caciques du parti qui en théorie
peuvent encore faire la décision il ya
ils sont l'objet de fortes pressions
aujourd'hui pour se décider vite et ne
pas contrarier le choix des électeurs à
tout cela on peut ajouter des problèmes
financiers pour la campagne d'hillary
clinton
en fait elles financent sa campagne
maintenant sur sa cassette personnelle
merci alain la russie elle a déjà son
nouveau président il a prêté serment
aujourd'hui lors d'une cérémonie au
faste impérial dimitri medvedev 42 ans
presque inconnu il ya quelques mois
encore succède à vlad
poutine qui en avait fait son dauphin
poutine nommé premier ministre qui
devrait rester le vrai maître du pays à
moscou laurent bouffier et xavier luizet
un cérémonial solennelle parfaitement
église 12 heures précises
après avoir traversé les grands salons
d'honneur du kremlin dimitri medvedev 42
ans très serment sur la constitution et
devient le troisième président de la
russie post communiste première
allocution premier message politique
devant la totalité des députés des
gouverneurs de provinces et des
ambassadeurs étrangers
il s'agit de respecter et de protéger
les droits et libertés de l'homme sont
les valeurs suprêmes de notre société
à moins d'un mètre l'admirent poutine le
visage impassible et l'ancien président
devenu premier ministre quitte le devant
de la scène mais reste l'homme fort du
pays grâce à des lois qu'il a lui même
récemment fait voter il garde la haute
main sur les services de sécurité sur la
nomination des hauts fonctionnaires et
sur les grandes compagnies comme gazprom
génératrice d'énormes profits financiers
ce sera donc un tandem qui va diriger la
russie un tandem avec un président sous
surveillance et un premier ministre très
puissant chef du parti majoritaire au
parlement russe
on en vient maintenant la situation en
birmanie avec d'abord cette dernière
minute la chargée d'affaires américaines
sur place vient d'indiquer que le bilan
pourrait dépasser les cent mille morts
avant d'évoquer les pressions
diplomatiques qui se multiplient pour
que le régime accepte d'ouvrir ses
frontières aux secours humanitaires
voici de nouvelles images reçues
aujourd'hui les premières tournées par
des journalistes indépendants
elles permettent de se faire une idée
plus précise de l'étendue des dégâts
attention si des enfants sont à vos
côtés certaines scènes peuvent choquer
claude sans père
pour la première fois cinq jours après
le passage du cyclone on commence à
percevoir l'ampleur des destructions sur
des kilomètres et des kilomètres au bord
des côtes tous les villages ont été
détruits à 95% dans cette région du
delta de l'irrawaddy vivait 24 millions
de personnes nous voici à beaugas là l
une des villes les plus touchées
les survivants se débrouillent comme ils
peuvent
ils s'entraident et partagent le peu
qu'ils ont ici se trouve un des rares
journalistes présents en birmanie
voici le centre de secours de bogal haye
je ne sais pas si on peut vraiment
appeler cela un centre de secours il n'y
a pas grand-chose à de médicaments les
gens ici ont tout perdu au fond de la
pièce un enfant veille sur un petit adri
elle n'a plus rien dit cette femme
on dépend de l'aide des moines un peu
plus loin la salle de soins
désespérément vide
les blessés attendent il n'y a aucun
médecin dans les rayons transport des
corps
la plupart sont déposées dans la rivière
voisine sans cérémonie aujourd'hui des
images échappant à toute censure nous
parviennent nous sommes ici à la puta
samedi dernier c'est une des ville du
détroit frappée par le cyclone
quelques heures après la tempête
mais survivants découvrent leur ville
ravagée
dans les rues les habitants se
débrouillent seuls pas d'hélicoptère pas
d'ambulance quelques volontaires de la
croix rouge sur un petit tracteur
complètement débordés et si personne
n'avait été averti de l'arrivée du
cyclone
ces touristes belges qui étaient en
voyage de noces en birmanie avaient eux
étaient prévenus à temps les hôtels de
la côte ont eu ordre du gouvernement de
fermer et de libérer tous les styles et
sur la côte
je pense que c'est limité à la
protection des touristes ce soir le
bilan officiel
impossible à vérifier est toujours de 23
mille morts et quarante et un mille
disparus
les gens qui n'ont plus d'abri qui enfin
qui font trade
les piles et les dans du riz aux plus
pauvres et ils en demandent donc de
nourriture manque d'offre le nu par le
désormais de plus d'un million de sans
abri et le gouvernement birman refuse
toujours l'entrée des équipes
humanitaires internationales et ce soir
une question agit donc toutes les
grandes capitales comment faire pour que
le régime birman accepte d'ouvrir les
frontières la france je vous le disais
par la voix de bernard kouchner se
prononce pour une résolution qui
imposerait à la dictature de laisser
passer l'aide
juste à temps vous juste avant de vous
entendre bernard kouchner nous allons à
bangkok c'est l'une des portes d'entrée
de la birmanie où seront regroupés une
partie des associations des équipements
aussi bon soir loïc de la mornais vous
êtes en direct c'est toujours le blocage
oui david et vous faites bien de parler
de blocage parce qu'on a entendu ou lu
ces derniers jours que l'aide arrivé au
compte gouttes mais c'est un 12-2 femise
tout est bloqué ici à bangkok
nous venons de rencontrer il ya quelques
instants des organisations humanitaires
des responsables des ong qui nous ont
raconté leur visite à l'ambassade de
birmanie aujourd'hui à bangkok qui nous
ont raconté ces fonctionnaires birman a
s'est désintéressé de la situation et
qu'ils auront clairement fait comprendre
qu'il n'y aurait aucun visa délivré pour
eux avant au moins le milieu de la
semaine prochaine
dans le meilleur des cas alors vous le
savez ici tout le monde sait que la
birmanie veut protéger complètement son
territoire nous avons nous sommes en
face d'un pays qui est un des plus
dictatoriaux de la planète et qui vient
d'annoncer de toute façon très
concrètement qu'ils étaient d'accord
pour recevoir une aide ma
feriel n'est pas une aide humaine la
birmanie ce soir semble se désintéresser
du sud est en tout cas semble prête à
sacrifier le sud du pays au nom d'une
certaine vision de la raison d'état
et ici tout le monde sait pertinemment
que les quelques humanitaires qui sont
en thaïlande aujourd'hui vont attendre
encore des jours avant de faire venir
leurs troupes ici car pour l'instant ça
ne servira à rien d'acheminer beaucoup
de matériel beaucoup dead et beaucoup de
personnel en thaïlande pour tout
simplement resté à l'hôtel
merci le hic bernard kouchner
déclarations remarquées donc de votre
part aujourd'hui vous vous prononcez
pour une résolution qui imposerait aux
autorités birmanes de laisser passer les
humanitaires le droit d'ingérence
comment pourrait-on forcer le régime
birman a laissé passer cette aide
faudrait que le conseil de sécurité
accepte que cette aide non politique si
je peux me permettre neutre parce qu'il
s'agit maintenant dans cette immense
catastrophe d'arrivée auprès des
victimes et de se courir
nous avons essayé déjà cet après midi le
conseil de sécurité n'a pas accepté il a
simplement accepté un certain nombre de
pays refusant d'aller plus loin d'en
discuter encore demain matin il y a eu
une déclaration de ban ki moon du
secrétaire général
exhortant les autorités birmanes à
laisser passer l'aide voilà ce que nous
pouvons faire des passes comment on peut
au prennent bien votre idée on
emploierait la force dans les géniaux
elle est épinglée dit imposé nous et
c'est non nous nous nous pourrions
essayer de convaincre de la nécessité
d'ouvrir l'aéroport de rangoun au vol on
dit qu'il y en a eu deux mais
apparemment votre correspondant ne les a
pas vus et ça n'est rien du tout face
aux besoins donc la communauté
internationale déciderait mais il faut
une résolution du conseil de sécurité
sans cela en effet il faut forcer
militairement ce qui est impossible et
ce qui n'est pas envisageable en ville
donc il faut encore une fois observé en
29 n'y avait pas de résolution sur la
responsabilité de protéger
issue d'un vieux combat français n'est
ce pas et bien en 29
il ya eu une aide internationale pour la
fin pour assister au moment de la
famille dans l'urss ne désespérons pas
mais là pour le moment ces blocs et vous
savez que le principe du droit
d'ingérence et controversé écouter relie
brauman en
un président lui aussi de médecins sans
frontières la saisine du conseil de
sécurité oui enfin l'idée de forcer les
barrages et d'installer l'aide dans le
dos du gouvernement birman ou en tout
cas en passant par dessus lui ça ça me
semble tout à fait extravagant et puis
c'est ouvrir la porte à des invasions de
toutes sortes pourquoi pas demain au
zimbabwe et au tibet en palestine
enfin il ya des tas d'endroits où la
responsabilité de protéger se pose en
des termes beaucoup plus aiguë que en
birmanie je rappelle qu'il ya pas de
risque vital aujourd'hui ça soulève des
objections vers la couche oui enfin si
on avait écouté robrig rony brauman on
n'aurait jamais rien fait n'est ce pas
et en palestine
en effet nous intervenons et dans bien
des endroits faut pas désespérer souffre
est ce qu'il ya des désespérés il faut
avancer alors avancé comment pour le
moment au conseil de sécurité s'est
bloqué mais il faut faire parvenir
l'aide aux ong qui sont sur place meiser
ces prêts à donner une aide
supplémentaire
oui bien sûr moi j'ai dit deux cent
mille euros parce que nous ne savions
pas comment ce serait appliquée nous
pouvons aller jusqu'à 1 2 million
d'euros pour le moment si c'est utile et
si c'est bien distribués donc notre pour
le moment notre désir c'est d'aller vite
vers les ambassades à new delhi à
bangkok et de faire parvenir cette aide
aux organisations françaises qui sont
surpassés en a six alors je crois que ce
sera efficace bien sûr ils peuvent pas
se déplacer bien sûr c'est désespérant
mais c'est le désespoir des gens qui
nous motive c'est très nécessité de
forcer la porte nous l'avons bien fait
dans des situations bout mais c'est sa
vie situation justement qui prête à
confusion forcé la porte forcée l'apport
ça peut vouloir dire par l'intérieur
conseil de la crainte non non c'est pas
une invasion
non c'est le conseil de sécurité
l'organisation responsable d'un certain
sens de la solidarité humaine
c'est-à-dire les nations unies et le
conseil de sécurité nous essayons
j'avais on nous avait dit la même chose
avant que ne soit accepté la
responsabilité de protéger est
maintenant la moitié des débats du
conseil de sécurité sont consacrés à
cela et nous y arriverons
un jour il y aura une responsabilité
humaine au delà de la souveraineté des
états et surtout la souveraineté des
dictatures merci bernard kouchner
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
l'économie en france contrairement à ce
qui était évoqué hier il n'y aura pas de
nouvelle augmentation des tarifs du gaz
de 11 5% pour le consommateur c'est le
ministre de l'écologie jean louis borloo
qui a fait cette mise en point c'est
tout à l'heure en fait il s'agissait
d'une proposition de la commission de
régulation de l'énergie
cette fois elle ne sera pas suivie
d'effet la fixation des prix du gaz est
assez complexe pour y voir clair
explications jean paul chapelle c'est un
répit pour le consommateur la facture de
gaz ne devraient pas augmenter à nouveau
le 1er juillet prochain
c'est le ministre de l'énergie qui s'y
est engagé cet après midi à l'assemblée
il est vrai que gaz de france a déjà
obtenu une augmentation de 5,5 pour cent
le mois dernier pour suivre la flambée
des cours mondiaux
mais dans la facture gdf il n'y a pas
que le gaz
il y a aussi les canalisations cent
trente mille kilomètres qu'il faut
entretenir et même remplacé pour des
raisons de sécurité sur la facture du
consommateur final vous avez vous
globalement deux parties une partie qui
est le gaz lui même qu'il faut acheter
le plus souvent étrangers puisque la
france ne produit pas son gaz cette
partie représente 70% à peu près
aujourd'hui de la facture est parti sur
les réseaux c'est celle dont on pas
aujourd'hui qui représente environ 30%
de la facture 1,5 pour cent de plus la
commission a proposé mais c'est l'état
qui a décidé des coûts supplémentaires
seront donc supporté par gaz de france
et ses concurrents
quant aux particuliers il n'est pas
forcément à l'abri d'une nouvelle hausse
si le cours du gaz comme celui du
pétrole continuent de flamber
je suis révolté c'est le cri lancé par
un colonel des pompiers responsable pour
la loire atlantique un coup de colère
assez rare dans la profession il
concerne l'absence de détecteurs de
fumée plusieurs incendies récents dans
la région ont montré qu'ils auraient pu
ces détecteurs sauver des vies une loi a
été proposé en ce sens mais elle n'a
jamais été votée vincent fichman damien
louvet
le feu a démarré dans la nuit c'était en
mars dernier alain sont dits banal dans
lequel on aurait certainement pu éviter
les trois morts que les pompiers ont
sorti 10 des cons
cette nuit là la famille berkane était
au grand complet y avait des vieilles
dans le couloir qui savait pas ce qui se
passait malgré l'odeur elle savait pas
s'il va les défendre ou rester savais
pas vraiment où est elle fait à ce
moment là on avait peur que le feu le
feu nous rattrape passer des moments
vraiment des moments difficiles dans
l'obscurité la panique domine et c'est
quasiment toujours le cas dans
l'immeuble aucun détecteur de fumée et
pourtant ces boîtiers aurait donné l'
alerte dès les premières fumées
un outil indispensable qui pourrait
sauver des vies en loire atlantique par
exemple deux incendies ont fait trois
morts en quelques jours le patron des
pompiers ne décolère pas il a fait des
détecteurs de fumée un combat personnel
ça fait plusieurs années déjà qu'on
parle beaucoup de du problème de la
détection d'incendié 14 dans les
immeubles d'habitation
je comprends pas quand on sait les
dégâts quand on sait les vies qui
pourraient être sauvées je ne comprends
pas d'autant plus incompréhensible 10
les pompiers qu'une proposition de loi
existe elle rendrait obligatoires les
détecteurs dans tous les foyers
elle a été présentée il ya trois ans il
n'a toujours pas été voté le blocage
comme c'est qu'il y à des lobbys
extrêmement efficace qui considère que
si cette proposition de loi passe il
faudra à ce moment là faire des dépenses
financières importantes et cela les
contrats vie désigner ouvertement
l'union sociale pour l'habitat c'est à
dire le représentant des offices hlm en
tant que propriétaire l'équipement au
détecteur leur coûterait 40 millions
d'euros
joint au téléphone lanco présentant se
défend d'en faire une question d'argent
ailleurs en europe les détecteurs ont
transformé les statistiques en grande
bretagne il aurait permis d'éviter un
incendie sur deux en bref deux enfants
de 7 et 9 ans sont morts noyés dans un
bras de la moselle près de ragon d'ange
profitant du beau temps ils se
baignaient en présence de leur mère ils
ont été emportés par le courant nouvelle
controverse
à propos des logements sociaux à paris
on sait que les listes d'attentes sont
très longues et bien le site internet
rue89 révèle que certains élus ou
d'anciens magistrats qui ne semble pas
dans le besoin bénéficie de certains de
ces logements en vertu de conventions
tout à fait légale par ailleurs enquête
frédéric protat patrick berton
voici une publicité dont christiane
taubira se serait bien passé la députée
de guyane dispose depuis dix ans dans un
logement social a ni hélène de 80 m²
pour un loyer de moins de 1000 euros
mais pour elle il n'y a rien d'anormal à
cela je sais bien que cette règle pour
moi de trouver des boucs émissaires
sur la question du logement le set est
moi j'ai un appartement qui est un
logement supplémentaire que depuis des
années je paie un loyer à fonds perdus
que je n'ai aucune influence sur la
fixation des loyers et que si ça peut
servir simplement a satisfait à quelques
rancoeurs tant pis ils ne seraient que
quatre ou cinq parlementaires à
bénéficier de ce type de logement grâce
à une convention signée il ya plus de 50
entre l'opa qui gère la plupart des
logements sociaux la capitale et les
deux chambres assemblée nationale et
sénat
une convention que certains députés eux
mêmes ne trouve plus du tout adaptée et
sans doute je dirais sans doute
justifiée il ya très longtemps quand ça
commence au 10 mai quand il n'est pas de
bureau chambre de résidence que prise en
charge les hôtels etc
faut arrêter ce type de cours
il n'y a plus de députés à la rue on n'a
pas à avoir de privilèges supérieur
à celles et ceux qui travaillent toute
la journée qu'ils sont fonctionnaires
qui travaillent dans depuis vécu en quoi
ces privilèges la chasse aux privilèges
des élus continuent lors de la dernière
campagne des municipales le maire du 12e
avait cru bon de se justifier de faire
visiter son appartement aux journalistes
deux mois auparavant le directeur de
cabinet de christine boutin locataires
pour 1200 euros seul mandat 180 m² de la
ville de paris et est contraint à la
démission social toujours en bref le
soulagement à saint nazaire et à méaulte
airbus renonce à vendre ses usines les
négociations en vue d'une cession ont
été rompues pour l'instant nous vous
l'annoncions dès hier pour la première
fois depuis longtemps il y aura une date
unique de rentrée scolaire après les
grandes vacances en septembre le 2
septembre
jusque là le retour en classe se faisait
de façon échelonnée car certaines villes
pratiquer la semaine de quatre jours
cette fois tout le monde sera logé à la
même enseigne puisque l'école du samedi
est supprimée
mais du coup les parents et les
enseignants doivent s'adapter à illkirch
près de strasbourg christine bost entier
stein schmidt dans ce centre de loisirs
c'est déjà presque les vacances pourtant
la date de la prochaine rentrée des
classes n'est plus à secrets ce sera la
même pour tout le monde
les septembre et auparavant c'était
quand 26 août
car ici dans les 14 écoles élémentaires
d'illkirch graffenstaden
on pratique la semaine de quatre jours
depuis sept ans avec une rentrée
anticipée et des petites vacances
écourtées
aujourd'hui c'est fini la semaine de
quatre jours sera généralisé sans
raccourcir les vacances
mauvais point selon les parents on
travaille avec les enfants il faut les
volets calvet
bon évidemment financièrement et vous
sur la place ou que le m pour la commune
qui accueille deux mille élèves la
rentrée unique le 2 septembre nécessite
une réorganisation de certains
personnels et suscite des interrogations
de la part des enseignants il y a en
effet une interrogation voir une
inquiétude quant à l'augmentation du
volume des programmes et autant lui qui
est diminué donc il ya quand même une
équation lac est un peu difficile à
résoudre
en attendant le centre de loisirs
accueillera les enfants une semaine de
plus fin août
encore faudra-t-il trouver de la place
un nouveau chantier gigantesque va
s'ouvrir dans les émirats arabes il
s'agit du pont le plus long du monde 40
km pour relier le qatar au royaume de
bahreïn il sera construit par le
français vinci romain mais si philippe
chasselas
le projet est monumentale 40 km de béton
posé sur la mer une alternance de digues
et de viaducs des haubans de 400 m ce
pont le plus long du monde reliera dans
cinq ans l'émirat du qatar au royaume de
bahreïn avec quatre voies de circulation
la traversée se fera en une demi-heure
contre un trajet de cinq
aujourd'hui c'est le groupe français
vinci leader mondial du bâtiment qui
sera le maître d'oeuvre de ce projet un
contrat de 3 milliards de dollars le
chantier s'annonce colossale et les
délais sont courts mais 20,6 en quête de
reconnaissance dans la région du golfe
veut frapper fort nous avons prévu de
faire 100 m de fond par jour
un pont sans maître traditionnellement
ça se construit en quatre ou cinq mois
et nous ferons 100 m de fond par jour je
crois que c'est après le tunnel sous la
manche le plus grand projet au monde qui
relie deux pays entre vos mains
inauguré il ya à peine huit jours le
pont dans 15 ou en chine avec ses 36 km
s'apprête déjà à être détrôné par le
projet du qatar autre géant au dessus
des mers le pont vasco de gama lisbonne
long de 17 km toujours plus légers
toujours plus résistants le béton et
l'acier d'un aujourd'hui aux architectes
la possibilité de voir toujours plus
loin
3 on a déjà approché le bosphore mais il
reste encore des grandes et gran via le
lien entre l'europe le lien physique
entre l'europe et l'afrique n'est pas
encore réalisé le lien entre la france
entre l'italie et la sicile est paralysé
il existe encore des liens et nord qui
sont dans les villages des ingénieurs
des concepteurs petit par la longueur
deux kilomètres et demi le viaduc de
millau n'en reste pas moins le pont le
plus haut du monde avec sa flèche de 343
m en bref au chili la ville de charlton
situés au pied du volcan du même nom
dans le sud du pays a été totalement
évacué l'alerté maximum a été décrété
hier on en parlait par les autorités
après l'augmentation sensible de
l'activité du volcan vous l'avez vu la
mer couvertes de cendres est devenue
blanche et grise les quelques 384
habitants ont été emmenés par voie
maritime laissant derrière
une ville déserte le début en israël des
célébrations du 60e anniversaire de la
création l'état hébreu des concerts sont
organisés un peu partout des cérémonies
aussi aujourd'hui un hommage était rendu
aux soldats tués au combat
on y reviendra plus longuement demain et
puis vives tensions au liban une grève
lancée pour les salaires s'est
transformé en campagne de désobéissance
civile du hezbollah aux axes routiers
ont été bloqués à beyrouth
des tirs sont entendus ce soir la
capitale semble paralysé l'inquiétude
est très vive
la visite en france de michaëlle jean à
l'occasion du 8 même son nom ne vous dit
sans doute rien à 50 ans elle est la
gouverneure générale c'est-à-dire la
chef de l'état canadien son poste
essentiellement honorifique mais au delà
de ses attributions
michaëlle jean est surtout le symbole
d'un pays où un habitant sur cinq est
immigré
elle est née en haïti elle est noire
elle est devenue une autorité morale
c'est le dossier de cette édition il est
signé dorothée olliéric franck brisset l
allure du r'n elle l'est d'ailleurs un
peu à sa façon puisque au canada elle
représente elizabeth 2 et la couronne
britannique
michaëlle jean 50 ans l'ancien réfugiés
haïtienne est désormais chef des forces
armées chef d'état elle est reçue pour
la première fois par son homologue
français nous l'avons rencontré à
l'ambassade du canada où elle nous a
livré un peu de son destin hors du
commun
je suis arrivée là réfugiés et me voilà
aujourd'hui à la tête de la plus haute
institution de l'état
c'est ça le canada c'est ça le canada
c'est possible c'est possible et bien
sûr la nomination de quelqu'un comme moi
souligne la modernité de ce pays son
retour en haïti et pleine d'émotion à 10
ans avec ses parents elle avait fui la
violence et la pauvreté de port au
prince
elle y revient en chef d'état en haïti
pour les plus pauvres
elle est devenue une héroïne réfugiés
donc au canada la jeune mickaël fait de
brillantes études et devient
présentatrice vedette de la télévision
c'est pas pour demain au proche-orient
et c'était vraiment le conte de fées est
en marche
vie leur carrosse tapis rouge la jeune
femme devenue gouverneur général en 2005
n'a rien oublié de son passé
c'est la première chose que j'ai dit que
lorsque j'ai été nommé mes ancêtres
étaient des esclaves vous rendez compte
il fonda l'impression que l'histoire
piétine la dépression que que la
barbarie nous rattrape mais de savoir
que kiel que l'on peut avoir ce type de
revanche sur l'histoire savoir que que
mes ancêtres étaient des sous-hommes il
est saoul femmes c'est comme ça qu'ils
ont été traités et aujourd'hui de de me
retrouver dans la position où je suis je
trouve que c'est une grande victoire
c'est une grande victoire
c'est ce que signifie mariée à un
français et mère d'une petite haïtienne
adopté
michaëlle jean lie désormais chaque
année le discours de la reine
d'angleterre
c'est ainsi dans les anciennes colonies
britanniques
celle que le protocole désigne comme son
excellence la très honorable michaëlle
jean poursuit son voyage officiel en
france
rencontre commémoration demain elle ira
se recueillir sur la tombe des soldats
canadiens tombés pour la france une
image de la star mondiale à paris hier
soir madonna concerts bref unique est
presque entièrement privé elle avait
choisi une salle à taille humaine
l'olympia madonna fera cinq enfants en
août toujours aussi survoltés et qui
cultive son look sexy et dominateurs ont
lé foot
moi
v
on a eu hier soir pour 1500 privilégié
qu'est ce qu'une oeuvre d'art un objet
une vision une expérience chacun se
posera la question au grand palais à
paris le célèbre sculpteur américain
richard serra y expose cinq plaques
d'acier de 75 tonnes chacune
sobre et monumental à la fois reportage
christophe airaud frédérick basile
c'est une exposition qui débute dans
l'oeuf ou des hauts fourneaux d'une
scierie puis le 22 avril dernier un
convoi exceptionnel cinq camions dans
les rues de paris sous la verrière du
grand palais quinze jours de chantier
cinq plaques d'acier 17 mètres de haut
et quatre mètres de large plantées dans
le sol
une sculpture signée richard ferrand en
fait il y a une force de 28 tonnes qui
s'exerçait directement sur le haut de la
plaque
la sculpture de richard serra et
monumental depuis 40 ans il installe à
travers le monde ses formes monumentale
mais délicate elle redessine les
paysages
je veux faire est à l'intersection de la
sculpture et de l'architecturé pour
rendre larchitecture vivante c'est la
voir d'un oeil neuf au grand palais
richard serra a nommé son travail
promenade un privilège pour le visiteur
en cette période où tout va vite
le sculpteur dit prends ton temps pour
regarder prend 30 ans voilà promène toi
il faut un petit peu de temps vraiment
ça se livrent pas instantanément
je dirais même que c'est quelque chose
que j'ai ressenti davantage jour suivant
j'ai encore le jour d'après je crois que
c'est pas tellement de l'aventuré avec
l'oeuvre en 1983 richard serra des
bosses clara clara un narco d'acier en
pl jardin des tuileries pour les micro
j'ai des riverains la sculpture est
retirée 25 ans plus tard à la drogue
tour
j'adorerais que la france conserve à
cette sculpture ici les coutumes de rye
rye ça ne dépend pas de moi mais si vous
me demandez si c'est mon réel et bien je
vous dis oui ça l'est maintenant c'est à
vous de voir vous avez quelques semaines
pour ressentir pour regarder pour voir
pour vivre avec l'oeuvre de richard
serra images de football en demi finale
de la coupe de france le paris saint
germain s'est imposé difficilement hier
sur la pelouse d'amiens 1 0 lui signé
yannick boli le neveu de basile boli bon
sang ne saurait mentir
le psg est donc qualifié pour la finale
il affrontera l'équipe victorieuse de la
deuxième demi finale match à suivre ce
soir en direct sur france 2 l'olympique
lyonnais reçoit sedan au stade de
gerland rencontre commentée par denis
balbir et xavier gravelaine ce sera donc
juste après ce journal avant de refermer
cette édition je vous en rappelle l'un
des principaux titres le dernier bilan
en birmanie selon la chargée d'affaires
américaines sur place il pourrait être
de plus de 100000 morts sur ce plateau
tout à l'heure bernard kouchner nous
confiait que la proposition française
d'une résolution imposant l'aide
humanitaire au régime avaient été
repoussés par l'onu deux navires
militaires sont en ce moment prêt à
délivrer une aide d'urgence c'est ce
qu'a indiqué pour sa part le ministre de
la défense français hervé morin
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
l'avoir suivi tout de suite la météo
laurent romejko point route valérie
maurice 20h50 du football donc avec
cette belle affiche lyon sedan en direct
du stade gerland
à demain
l'info en continu c'est aussi sur france
2 point fr